if I was talking to rapael Nadal or
Novak jovic I'd be like yeah no 100% but
P's Morgan it's like it's a problem
people think that I've been entitled and
got given everything off a plate but you
hold a gun to my to my mom and to come
steal a kardes the curios family is
definitely dealt with their fair share
of racism um in Australia when they're
all going nuts what do you actually feel
you feel like the bad guy in in a movie
you feel like the main villain every
time I went out on the court I knew that
I could spoil someone's day I love it
tonight on PE Morgan un sense that the
Royal race R is reignited as a
translation supposedly of omis sco's new
book named two senior Royals who were
accused of making racist inferences
tonight I'll reveal who the Royals are
that were named in this erroneous part
of this Dutch version of a book and
we'll debate whether it's time for the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex to denounce
the author and his in my view baseless
claims also he's the quitted killo
became one of the most divisive figures
in America two years after he walked
free from Court Kyle Rittenhouse says
he's still trying to clear his name he
joins me live and as the clock takes
down on the truce in Gaza should Israel
extend the Pauls or finish the job will
[Music]
debate live from the news building in
London this is is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Pi Morgan uncensored Harry
and Megan's claims about supposed
racists and the royal family have left a
predictable and poisonous Legacy for the
last few years we live in an age where
grievances are given the benefit of the
doubt where the establishment is Toxic
by default where my truth apparently
means more than the truth they knew the
power their words would hold and many
people across the world took their words
at face value now almost three years on
Britain is still dealing with the for
out from
this and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's
born what
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like hold up hold up there s
there's several conversations there's a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look
like and you're not going to tell me who
had the
conversation I think that would be very
damaging to them okay
compartmentalized that if he were
to
Brown that that would be a problem are
you saying that I wasn't able to follow
up with why but that if that's the
Assumption you're making I think that
feels like a pretty safe one
you may recall that I lost my previous
job for responding to these claims by
saying I didn't believe a word of it
well Harry and Megan have never provided
any evidence for that highly incendiary
claim it's not like they haven't had the
chance to after all they pumped out six
hours of self-indulgent build on Netflix
trashing Britain and the press for its
racism but didn't mention what they said
on opra Harry wrote 150,000 words of
family bashing poison in his Memoir
spare and the TV studios to promote it
but didn't mention what they'd said to
Oprah Winfrey megum had a 12-part
podcast on Spotify I didn't mention it
either it's like it never happened like
it
disappeared clearly neither of them go a
damn about rawal protocol or family
privacy in fact they buil a whole
industry around violating their own
privacy and that of their relatives
instead of backing up those claims about
racism on their Relentless publicity
tour Harry did a sort of strange u-turn
didn't he a few months ago tried to
pretend they never said them it was it
was us it was the
media in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well of the British press
said that right I did did Megan ever
mention that they they
racist she said there were troubling
comments about concern about his skin
color right wouldn't you describe that
as essentially racist I wouldn't not
having lived within that family took him
two years years to do that Utah two
years of the royal family or a bunch of
racists flying around the world I was in
America through a lot that period and
they all believed it because it had
appeared on Oprah then he says I didn't
never meant to say anything about racism
what are you all talking about it's the
beastly media well now Harry and Megan's
lick spittle client journalist omed
scobby the man who lied about his age
said he was 33 when in fact he was 38
bit older now said he never used private
Jets and then got reminded of an
Instagram picture of him the week before
he denied that this week showing him on
a private jet the man who said that I
have regular phone calls with Quin
ciller regular phone calls never had one
phone call with Quin ciller in my entire
life I'd like to but she doesn't call
well scobby is back with a spiteful Li
filled new book that's poured fuel on
the Flames he says that Megan wrote
private letters to King Charles naming
two Royals who she accuses of taking
part in those supposedly troubling
conversations about Archie skin color
scob initially said he knew the names
but couldn't legally report them but of
course he could have done outside of the
UK he could have done it in America if
he wanted to where the book is published
could done it anywhere but he said he
never names names which is another of
his lies and yet overnight they were
sensationally revealed suddenly out of
nowhere in the Dutch version of scobie's
book journalists had been sent copies
and the book was briefly on sale in
bookstores before being suddenly
withdrawn in a dash by the Publishers
scob initially said it was a translation
error which didn't really make any sense
because how do you mistranslate
names they're either there or they're
not the publisher now says wasn't
translation it was simply an
error but how did that error happen how
is there an entire different version
appearing in a Dutch edition of this
book the consequence of the error is
that millions of people online around
the world now know the Royals are again
being implicated in what I think is a
completely baseless claim of inferred
racism there is again massive
speculation about who the people are who
were supposedly making comments about
Archie skin color which is incredibly
unfair to all the Royal Family they've
all been tired with this brush now for
years well I'm going to end all this
nonsense because frankly if a book is on
the streets in Holland available to
Dutch people containing names the omed
scobby the lick spittle scribe for the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex the man who
you may remember denied they had any any
involvement in the last book and so did
Megan do you remember nothing to do with
it but then in court many months after
the book was published lished under oath
she had to admit she had emailed her
AIDS briefing notes for when they met
scobby so she was one of his primary
sources on that first book now again
we're being told she had nothing to do
with this and maybe she didn't and maybe
we should be believing omis scobby when
he says he did not ever write these
names down in any draft of his book it
just somehow popped up in the Dutch
version of the book
how I've written 10 books I think it is
now I've never had a version of my book
pop up in a foreign Edition that
contained unbelievably damning
allegations about two of the most famous
people in the world and I had nothing to
do with it and didn't know how it got
there and nor did anybody else how does
it get there Omid surely you as the
author me you must be furious right you
must be demanding head roll and you want
names don't you ironically omed about
who did this to you who smed your
reputation as an author I would omed I'd
want to know right now especially if I
was trying to convince the world that I
had nothing to do with it myself and I'd
never ever put these names in writing
and maybe some lawyer had come along and
told me not to I mean I couldn't
possibly have happened because you've
given us your word and as I've
established so far in this monologue
your word is your bond and should be
taken as sacr Saint well I'm going to
cut through all this crap I'm going to
tell you the names of the two senior
Royals who are named in that Dutch
version of the book because frankly if
Dutch people wandering into a Bookshop
can pick it up and see these names then
you British people here who actually pay
for the British royal family you're
entitled to know too and then we can
have a more open debate about this whole
farago because I don't believe any
racist comments were ever made by any of
the royal family and until there is
actual evidence of those comments being
made I will never believe it but now we
can start the process of finding out if
they ever got uttered what the context
was and whether there was any racial
intent at all like I say I don't believe
there was the Royals who are named in
this book are King Charles
and Catherine Princess of
Wales we'll join him in now is the Royal
editor of the Sunday Times Roy niika who
just discovered I was going to do that
Royal biographer Tom bow who also just
discovered going to do that and the
professor of black studies at Birmingham
University kahindi Andrews but first the
Dutch Royal journalist Rick IAS who has
read the damning excerpt because he's
seen it in the Dutch version um let me
talk to you Rick first of all uh when
you first saw what appeared in the Dutch
version what did you
think well I wouldn't think I would have
some big scoop because I I was thinking
that everyone in the whole world would
have the same copy except it would be in
English so I didn't I I wasn't aware
that it was such a big thing how do you
think of course it is a big thing that
their names are in it but um everyone
would would have the same same copy
isn't it usually well I didn't I I
couldn't work out in my rational head
why you should know what those names
were but British people shouldn't so
that's why I've said them um and to
repeat I don't believe a word of these
racism claims never have done I've seen
no evidence to suggest they're true I
think it was an ugly smear and now at
least we can have a public debate about
it and people can say what they really
want to say about it but from your
perspective how do you think these
paragraphs appeared in the Dutch version
if omed scobby the author insists as he
has done that he had nothing to do with
it never put these names in writing
never supplied a draft with those
names first of all I want to say um
after your track record Pierce um it
would be would be very uh unimpressed if
you didn't mention these names so uh
well done because you're the first one I
think on TV that that's doing that um
well I to be honest with you I don't I
don't understand why why journalists
wouldn't I haven't understood why we
haven't so far because the moment a book
book is published and available to
people on the streets of another country
containing these names um you know I
don't I don't even know if these are the
two names of the two people that Megan
Markle originally with Harry claimed
made these comments we don't know um but
we do know they've appeared in the book
a version of the book and it's om sco's
book and we do know that under oath Mega
marle admitted that she she conspired in
his last book as one of his sources so
let's wait let's wait and see how this
plays out but again just to come back
what do Dutch people in the media think
has happened
here well I don't think Dutch people
really care about it but because it's
it's it's the the US royal family in
this case that is uh is involved not
even the British royal family actually
because people don't believe it I think
um but the other hand how did it end up
in the book I think it's it is in the
way om is describing it um it was not in
the the manuscript what is the
manuscript is it the final version that
you hand in in your at your publisher in
that case it was an earlier version and
it got erased in all the other versions
all over the world except for that tiny
little country the Netherlands that has
been overlooked uh maybe someone
overlooked uh the Netherlands to send us
a memo the publisher or maybe the
publisher forgot to do it I don't know
well it's very mysterious let me go to
another seasoned author Tom B you've
written many books have you ever known a
situation Tom where a version of your
book has appeared in a foreign version
containing paragraphs you knew nothing
about that contain bombshell Revelations
it's impossible and also more to the
point he also complained that the French
translations were wrong too I mean the
problem with scobby is everyone is
getting it wrong what he wrote but of
course he can't probably remember what
he wrote himself because it's so full of
fabric well I'm not saying he's lying
about having no involvement in this I'm
just saying I'm just saying generally
he's a terrible liar he's a terrible
liar uh we know that from his own
statement about the briefing from Jason
knal on which Megan gave him we know
he's a liar and I think he's fabricated
a lot in his book and he lied when he
said he didn't have Megan's help in this
book clearly he was briefed by Megan's
people from California he says they
share mutual friends right but those
friends would not be allowed to
cooperate with him without permission
exactly exact before this is all this
his book again is Megan's voice
why is she decided to launch Another War
a battle against the raw family that's
for her to explain but she hasn't
dissociated herself from um have you
ever thought that there was any racial
intent any comments made no no I mean
the whole this is actually explained in
my Megan book very clearly it was a very
very early on in Harry's relationship
with Megan he goes for Te to clarence's
house he's sitting there with King
Charles Prince Charles then and Camila
and and they eventually discover who he
dating and all the rest of it and Camila
very as a joke just says I wonder what
your baby will look like well he he go
she have ginger hair it's just the
normal and when that that originally
came out it had nothing to do with
racism as Harry himself admits it was
all to do with a perennial problem what
will your baby look like if it comes
from different parents I just thought it
was incredibly disingenuous of Harry
after two years feverish racism
slurs he then said he then said oh he
never meant to racism no no but the
whole point is in the Opera interview
that he comes on to the program after
Megan has spoken and says no she's wrong
it all happened long before she was
pregnant it happened right at the
beginning of our relationship it was
just a normal tea conversation two years
before exactly and so Megan had lied I
mean there were 17 lies she uttered in
the Opera interview that was one of her
lies and that is the problem he's now
hoist by it but the real problem he caus
enormous damage and scob huge damage and
scobby to get some money and all does it
again and again again but this time yet
again is definitely with Megan's
approval okay Roy look you didn't know I
was going to do the naming of these two
people I don't want to get you involved
in that directly you're a royal
correspondent but on the wider picture
this book is getting more and more
attention it's now front page news of
many papers it clearly has a lot of
damaging Revelations it follows a
familiar pattern from his first book all
the main Royals are awful J and dutches
are susex are Angelic and weren't they
treated so badly um how significant is
this book is it going to actually have
any real effect do you think well it's
interesting you say it's full of
damaging Revelations and Bombshells
because actually from what I have read
so far it's just full of omid's own
highly partisan views and opinions
rather than fact-based damaging bomb
allegations that I think uh a lot of
people thought were going to be unveiled
with real proper evidence behind them
and I have to say I've been asked about
the book a lot this week and it's just
felt quite predictable and of course it
was always going to get lots of traction
because it's Omid it's the Royals but it
just feels once again like finding
Freedom a very one-sided partisan the
rest of the royal family awful Harry and
Megan men of roses and I think actually
the British public and a lot of The
Wider public are able to sort of decide
for themselves which camp they're in how
much they believe how much they don't I
mean you've talked about already this
week the things that Omen has said about
you that aren't true he's he's he really
not a fan of the Sunday Times coverage
I've read and he had a wi and a moan
about my William interview knocking off
trooping the color from the front page
we never put trooping the color on the
front page and so on and so forth so I
think is it going to be hugely damaging
I think it'll whip up a storm
predictably you know to get publicity
and I feel that possibly something
around these names could be to do with
publicity but I don't think it's going
to have real lasting damage because I
don't think people are going to believe
every all his opinions right and that
and and they shouldn't by the way from
my experience but in terms of I guess
the the family relationship sh here
particularly Harry and his father we
were reading signs of potential reproach
more would they come to sandum I got to
say I think I've got more chance of
being at Sandringham than Mega Marco
pulling my story crackers they'd like to
yeah um it was your story yeah um but
none of this is going to help because
there is this belief which may or may
not be true in the case of this book
that's I don't know right but we know in
the first book Mega marle said she had
nothing to do with it and then under
Roth had to admit she did
if if it turns out the same has happened
here and she's authorized friends to
help him and give him stuff because
let's face it this exchange of letters
between Charles and and Megan Markle
only one of them can have told people
about that and Charles is not the kind
of guy that's going to be telling people
about letter like that which makes me
think it's her and her friends or
somebody has gone to scob we'll wait and
see but if that is the case this is
going to be very damaging to the ongoing
trust issues between Charles and Harry
well trust is the key is I think that
was something I I touched on in that
piece about them saying we wouldn't
decline an invitation to spend time with
the family the problem is as As You Just
Right rightly Said imagine what a whole
Christmas at Sandringham um would would
produce in terms of potential you know
potential future content and I think
looking at you know the phone call
between Charles and Harry and Megan um
around Charles 75th birthday it was
briefed before it happened and it was
briefed after and I think if you can't
even have a private phone conversation
that isn't briefed before and or after I
honestly wouldn't trust if if that was
someone in my family after what they've
done yeah repeatedly repeatedly
repeatedly I wouldn't trust them as far
as I could throw them trust is the issue
and that's not changing anytime soon
let's go to kahindi Andrews be waiting
uh patiently here kahindi we've talked a
lot about uh race issues over the years
but specifically here there is no doubt
that when they went on Oprah Winfrey uh
two years ago they made a series of
allegations directly inferring racism by
senior members M of the royal family
which they've never produced evidence
for and which two years later Harry said
oh we didn't mean racism we meant
unconscious bias and so on do you not
feel that that is incredibly damaging to
people like you who constantly fight
battles for racial equality racial
Justice you know try and and fight
proper battles about this is it not
incredibly damaging to that when someone
of their
profile tries to pretend what they said
to Oprah Winfrey was not what it
was well no I mean I think the
allegations when they came out we all
kind of believed it it wasn't something
that seems completely outrageous also
I'm not sure what evidence you could
have and actually if you listen to the
clips they're clearly trying not to say
the names because they know the names
are going to cause this massive storm I
think the bigger problem with the whole
way this has been has been portrayed is
Oprah is shocked everybody's
shocked no black person I know was
shocked that this came up in a
conversation in the royal family and the
bigger problem here really is that
actually it isn't about racist Royals
it's about the the royal family is
racism it is a symbol of white supremacy
that's the bigger problem way talk about
this now is completely because they're
white no not because they're white but
not because they're white because they
are exclusiv where the evidence of them
being white supremacist they link back
to the col they link back to colonialism
why do we even idea that a country like
Britain which is incredibly diverse an
Empire which was more diverse is by this
almost exclusively white family into the
21st century I'm sorry that is you're
judging them by by their skin the issue
of racism so you're just to be clear
you're judging them by their skin color
not the content of their characters no
I'm say I'm saying their skin color is
Not an Accident it is not an accident
that
Mega they can't help being white
accident she she's run out of
the we can't help our skin color it's
not it's not about their skin color it's
about what it represents the idea that
the that King Charles is the king of my
family is from Jamaica which is 90%
black people and the king of the head of
state of Jamaica is this is the King
Charles it's ludicrous that is a
ludicrous thing in the 21st century but
that is what I'm saying symbol of white
supremacy have a vote I couldn't care L
if it was Kate listen countries like
Jamaica will have votes and they can
having a vote it's about the No No but
it's about there are countries choosing
there are countries like Jamaica
choosing whether they want to go
independent that's absolutely democ
right you don't have to
have the head of the fact that's a
choice the fact that's a choice in the
21st century tells you there's a big
problem do you think anyone anyone in
the royal family just to be clear anyone
in the royal family as far as you're
concerned is a white supremacist simply
because they're white and they're part
of the royal family this what I'm saying
is this the royal family like the police
or like universities or I work they are
they are institutions of white supremacy
it's not about the indiv indviduals it's
about what they do it's about their role
in the world that's the real case the
royal family should be gone it should be
abolished shouldn't exist if we're
talking about anti-racism I really
couldn't get less which which Royal said
what because that's not that actually
distract what if they didn't say it at
all Earth would accept what if they
didn't say it at all but the whole world
has been LED for two three years to
believe that they did what about that
scenario like I said like I this doesn't
like for me it really doesn't matter if
they said it or not it's not any not
about individual people so it's they are
all racist they are in in an institution
which is racism which is one of the
primary symbols of racism you know
sometimes think he's a bit surprising
that K I think I going to say sometimes
you know when when your default position
which it always is by the way is that
everyone's a white supremacist if they
got white skin color until they can
prove otherwise it is your default
position it is your default positions
you know know what I that's always been
your default position I said that the
institution any white people in any
position of authority anything they're
all white
supremacist it do beg the question why
you want to live in a country like this
if they're all white like the they I
should I I should I can go home back to
Jamaica unfortunately head of state is
the king it's the same problem I can't
even get away from where the hell you
like I'm just saying why why honestly
why why stay in a country you believe is
Led in every pillar of the establishment
and Society by white supremacist makes
no sense to me cu the reality is that
that's the world that I I didn't choose
the world that is the world that I
inhabit and I will just stress I'm not
saying that all white people are white
supremist I actually think when we think
about racism that individual racist it's
the worst way to think about it think
about the systems think about the
institutions and the royal family is
exclusively white for a reason it is the
head of the So-Cal commonweal British
Empire for a reason it is a direct
connection to the Colonial history that
this country loves so much it is the
premier sybol of white supremacy could
one of those it's actually not
exclusively white comments it's not
exclusively White because the Duchess of
suiv D of Sussex is not white almost
exclusiv what she did do was she entered
the the r she launched a grenade of uh
racism allegations and has ever since
stayed silent about those bar did let
let them let them run around the
world I mean that to me she came into
the family and her black so so much of
an a everybody lost their minds that in
it way is a form of racism actually in
my view what she's done um but we'll see
we'll see how this all plays out now
because i' I've decided to name the two
people named in the holl version of his
book let's let's see how this plays out
let's see whether Megan marle and Harry
were involved with Scooby's book let's
see what scobby and his involvement in
this offending paragraph and naming was
let's just see how this all plays out
and let's give the members of the royal
family that they besched collectively
let's give them the chance to properly
respond because I don't believe a word
of it anyway kahindi uh it's always good
to talk to you thank you very much Tom
good to see you Roy thank you very much
indeed and S next one of the world's
leading Jewish legal experts says all
options are on the table when it comes
to Israel self defense including the
nuclear option we'll debate with
Professor Alan dtz
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we're on your smart speaker as
well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know I love bort
today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police appro Palestine that is just
not right you swearing off in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about 3 years hundreds and hundreds
of mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got a
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually Shar your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
kids think all they have to do is take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok problem solve this is really
unfair what what what's unfair if it's
on camera we're not doing interviews yes
I'm going to do I'm you're going to Res
yes cuz I cannot continue my work when I
say I am God I'm not joking did you feel
Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
is actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
you can't can you I've asked you two
questionss should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
welcome back to our sensor the clock is
ticking tonight on Israel's truce in
Gaza as many debate whether the
ceasefire should be made permanent
others argue that Israel must be allowed
to finish the job of eradicating Hamas
I'm now joined by Professor Alan d
through a war against the Jews how to
end Hamas barbarism and to debate him
the Palestinian American columnist Omar
bad well welcome to both of you um Alan
d let me start with you uh obviously
your book very timely um you know I've
spoken a lot in the last couple of
months of the moral quandry I feel about
what is going on in Gaza I have no moral
quandry about what happened on October
the 7th it was an appalling terror
attack I have no quandry about Israel's
right and duty to defend itself the
quandry I have is whether what is going
on in Gaza is a proportionate response
given the massive civilian death toll
and given that so many of them are
children do you understand that moral
quander and what is your response to it
I fully understand it and I blame it
100% on Hamas which uses children as
human Shields it has a strategy its
supporters call it the CNN strategy I'm
more direct I call it the dead baby
strategy what Hamas does is they kill as
many Israeli Jews as possible knowing
that Israel is going to have to respond
by going after their commanders their
tunnels and their rockets and so they
hide their commanders their tunnels and
their Rockets among babies and children
and and civilian ions and then when
Israel responds and tries to conduct a
military operation to prevent recurrence
of these uh barbarisms they bring the
dead babies in front of CNN and the New
York Times and the world of course sheds
tears as we all shed tears whenever we
see a dead baby and the World Turns
against Israel and then Hamas does it
again and again and again it's been
doing it for 20 years with great success
because the media plays into it so there
is a great moral conjur but you know if
I were to rob a bank and hold you uh
Pierce as a hostage and then start
shooting on the police and an attempt to
stop me from shooting or accidentally to
shoot and kill you under British law
under American law and Sharia law the
responsible person is not the person
whose bullet killed the uh hostage it's
the hostage taker who's guilty of murder
okay so yes there's a a moral conundrum
but Hamas is responsible for causing it
okay uh Omar I mean there's no doubt
that the scale of what Hamas did on
October the 7th was so overwhelming and
horrendous that Israel was always going
to respond like this Hamas knew that and
my I guess my question off the top to
you is how did that serve the
Palestinian people how does what Hamas
did on the scale that it did it knowing
what the response would be knowing
thousands of innocent Palestinians would
die very quickly as a consequence as
well as people in Israel how did that
help the Palestinian
people I think there's a bigger question
here as far as context is concerned
which is that the single biggest organ
terrorist organization in all of
Palestine and Israel is known as the
Israeli government and the military wing
of this terrorist organization which is
orwellian named the Defense Forces of
Israel has engaged in massive war crimes
for decade after decade against
Palestinians engaging in the mass
killing of Palestinian civilians in land
theft in denial of water I mean just the
list of atrocities goes on and on and on
and if we want to just go by a timeline
a question might be
why did the terrorist government of
Israel think it can impose decade after
decade of occupation and Siege on
Palestinians and deny them any Prospect
for a better future and not think that
there's going to be a reaction of sorts
so we have this a little bit backwards
we have this arbitrary starting point of
an attack by Hamas which had it been
confined to military targets could have
been uh con you know construed as an act
of legitimate resistance but because it
also included attacks horrendous attacks
on Israeli civilians obviously these
kinds of Acts are indefensible but
ultimately we are talking about a
situation in which Israel is initiating
violence in which Israeli terrorism
dwarfs anything that Hamas has ever done
and we're watching that even expand to a
more monstrous scale now we're talking
about an apartheid government that is
engaging literally in the mass
starvation of a civilian population and
mass terrorism killing them by the tens
of thousands and the question is has it
gone too far I shudder to live in a
world where that's even a question of
course these kind of atrocities have to
come to let me go back to Alan I mean
this is the problem Alan that I think
Israel has in terms of global opinion
here especially from America which
obviously will play a key role um if as
as the report suggest once this uh
temporary pause is over they start
barreling through the south of Gaza it
does beg the question well what is going
to happen at the end of this is is the
military plan to Simply level the whole
of Gaza to the ground with perhaps 50 to
100 thousand or more uh civilians killed
in the process and is there any
guarantee of two things one that you
actually get rid of Hamas by doing that
because at the moment they can't say
I've already interviewed Israeli
government spok they can't tell you how
many Hamas terrorists they've actually
killed they don't know right and it may
be they've all disappeared um but is
that part of the military plan and if it
is what's the plan after this what
happens to all the displaced Palestinian
people they've got no homes to go back
to and how do you avoid the obvious in
my opinion consequence of this which is
just a massive increase in
radicalization from all those who've
seen their relatives blown to
Pieces well the plan Israel has had
since 1948 has been a two-state solution
it was offered to the Palestinians by
the UN they said no in 1967 again they
said no in 1990 in
221 2007 in Gaza they ended the
occupation and then Hamas by a military
coup took over I haven't seen a single
sign U of protest calling for a
two-state solution Hamas is against the
two-state solution in its Charter it
wants to eliminate Israel completely
from The River To The Sea Palestine will
be free free of what free of Jews and
then the signs also say we want to clean
the world clean the world of Jews that's
what the Nazis said they called Jews
dirty and Vermin so the answer has to be
a two-state solution and and a peaceful
two-state solution solution but you
can't have a two-state solution with
Hamas because hamas's Charter is against
it maybe the Palestinian Authority yes
so I'm in favor of doing what the United
States did after the second world war
they totally destroyed Nazism lots of
people died lots of civilians died but
there wasn't an increase in radicalism
uh the German people realized that
getting rid of the nazzis was the best
thing that could happen to the German
people I'm hoping that the Palestinian
people will realize that the same is
true if Hamas is ended the Palestinian
people have a great future Gaza can be
Singapore and the Mediterranean instead
of a place where terrorism thrives
feeding hungry people Omar I mean do you
believe there's any future for Gaza that
involves Hamas at this
stage I think that's unavoidable I mean
honestly just the the onslaught of
untruths from Alan dtz I mean the only
person who has less regard for truth
than Donald Trump is perhaps dtz and
it's it's hard to know where to begin to
respond to all of this let me say a
little let me just say yeah well I'm I'm
willing to back it up with actual facts
so here we go first of all question
human shield say WR if let let me point
it all out to you here listen up first
of all on the question of human Shields
there is no question that Hamas hides in
civilian areas that's as a result of the
imbalance of power where Israel has
fighter jets that fly in the sky and a
massive milit a regular military force
but the issue of human Shields the
definition of human Shields is holding
civilians against their will and putting
them in front of you in combat to deter
enemy fire and the only party in this
conflict that has ever done that
documented by major human rights
organizations and a matter of fact is
actually the Israeli military using
Palestinian civilians including children
as human Shields that was a matter of
policy from 2000 until 2005 the Israeli
Supreme Court said that has to come to
an end in 2005 the Israeli military uh
protested that decision because it is
very useful for them to continue using
Palestinian civilians as human Shields
and even though the Israeli Supreme
Court banned it the Israeli military
continues to use it to this day there
have been numerous occasions documented
by Human Rights Watch by Amnesty
International and other organizations
and it tells you what this lie is
ultimately about because if it is true
that Palestinian militants do not care
about the lives of Palestinian children
then what is the point of the Israeli
military using Palestinian children as
human Shields when they are in these
confrontations so that is simply
just don't use blame Palestinians for
their own let me get a final quick
response please a quick response
Adam if the Palestinian uh terrorists
put down their arms there would be peace
if Israel put down its arms there would
be genocide of the kind that occurred on
October 7th Israel cannot cannot put
down its arms because we know what Hamas
did on the 7th they would have done to
every Israeli if they had the ability to
do that and that's why Israel must of
and that will benefit the world and that
will benefit the Palestinians and that
will lead to a two-state solution which
is not what my distinguished
opponent the two solution argument is
nonsense throughout the entire so-called
peace process when Israel was pretending
to be engaged in a peace process support
for Palestinian violence simply
disappeared and in spite of that Israeli
land theft continued unabated building
more
occurred right after the offer of
soltion
gentle has no interest in
allans we' run out of time I appreciate
you both joining me it's an important
debate we'll keep having it please both
of you come back again I appreciate it
in a moment we'll be talking to Kyle
Rittenhouse first let have a look at
exclusive interview we've got coming up
on tomorrow's show something very
different with the bad boy of tennis and
World sport Nick
curios never seen an Australian Suk like
curios embarrassing to which you
responded E A eat
a sometimes you are a bit of gu I could
be a douche on the tennis court but I
think we're very
alike how would you feel if while we're
talking right now I just start munching
on Sushi if I was talking to rapael
Nadal or Novak jovic i''d be like yeah
no 100% but here's Morgan it's like it's
a problem people think that I've been
entitled and got given everything off a
plate but you hold a gun to my to my mom
and to come steal a car it's the curios
family has definitely dealt with their
fair share of racism um in Australia
when they're all going nuts what do you
actually feel you feel like the bad guy
in in a movie you feel like the main
villain every time I went out on the
court I knew that I could spoil
someone's day I love
[Music]
it
that's a great interview in N cuos
definitely worth watching tomorrow night
something very different uh my next
guest is one of the most controversial
figures in recent American history kyl
writtenhouse appeared self-defense when
he was charged with murdering two people
during the Wisconsin black lives matter
writs of 2020 and the jury agreed for
some written house has become a heroic
standard Bearer The Second Amendment in
Americans rights to bear arms for others
he got off because of privilege now two
years after his trial ended he's written
a book called acquitted to tell his side
of the story and he joins me now live
from Florida car rhous thank you very
much indeed for joining me um first of
all let me just ask you if you had your
time again would you a 17 have put an
AR-15 semi-automatic rifle around your
neck and gone purposefully down to where
these protests were happening knowing
what was going to
transpire well Pierce thank you for
having having me on with hindsight being
2020 as it always is no I wouldn't have
gone but that doesn't change the fact
that I was attacked and I defended
myself I was there to help people and
provide first aid and that's what I did
I'm on video that night providing first
aid and helping people and then being
ambushed and cornered and forced to use
my rifle to defend myself you killed two
people and you wounded a third how do
you feel about
that well Pierce they attacked me they
left me with no choice I have nightmares
every night of being attacked and being
ambushed and them trying to steal my gun
and pointing guns in my face it's not an
easy thing to do but I did what I had to
do to stay alive and if I didn't I would
be dead yeah listen you were acquitted
and many in America believe that you had
the absolute right to defend yourself
I'm just curious on a human level you
know you're very young even now what are
you 20 years old now
yes sir and and you've killed two human
beings and wounded a third I just wonder
how that
feels I don't think that's an
appropriate question to ask how it feels
it's not an easy thing to do it's
something I live with every single day
it's nightmares I have it's something
that I have to deal with I have to deal
with the PTSD and the trauma from having
to do
that right I mean but it seems to me
your emotions are more about you and
your trauma because your life was being
threatened and and that side of it
rather than the question I'm asking
which is simply on a human level how do
you feel about being so young and yet
having on the record for the rest of
your life now that you took the lives of
two people regardless of the
circumstances
and and like I just said it's something
I deal with every day I deal with the
PTSD and the trauma and the nightmares
it's not easy to deal with
it your book um presumably you're going
to make money from this book do you feel
comfortable making money from from this
which ultimately is a a tragic story um
you know I again I repeat you were
acquitted there's no reason you can't do
a book but do you feel comfortable
making a lot of money out of essentially
what in the end was an incident that
cost the lives of other
humans well I'm not writing the book to
make money I'm writing the book to tell
the story of what happened I'm telling
trying to change the narrative that
media keeps putting out there that I'm
some type of white supremist racist
person when that's just not true I'm a
20-year-old kid who was put in a
situation to where I was forced to
defend myself and I'm writing to put
that into aook I wrote to put that I
wrote a story and put that in a book so
I can share that with everybody so they
can understand what I went through how
my childhood was growing up and the
difficulties I deal with today and you
can check out the book at Rittenhouse
book.org if you want to read it and
learn the truth for yourself how do you
feel that you became a hero to many on
the far right kind of made you that
poster
boy well Pierce I'm not a hero I did
what I had to do to to defend myself
there are countless Americans every day
that defend themselves and it's not a
heroic thing to do it doesn't make you a
villain but it doesn't make you a hero
it's doing the right thing to to stay
alive if I didn't if I didn't defend my
myself I wouldn't be here talking today
you were 17 at the time you were too
young to legally acquire the gun that
you used that's not true it's not
true that is not true Wisconsin statute
says a person under between the ages of
16 17 can car can carry a long rifle
with a barrel longer than 16 in that's
Wisconsin law and the judge dismissed
that charge okay so you were let me ask
you look I I'm in the country right now
I've talked about this many times both
here and in America and I learned
Americans want to handle their own gun
culture the way they want to handle it I
respect that but let me ask you do you
think it's right that 17y olds in
America in Wisconsin should be able to
carry around semi-automatic rifles like
an
AR-15 our founding fathers were very
intentional when they wrote the
Constitution they didn't put an age
limit on how old you have to be to um
exercise the Second Amendment but they
did say it would be part of a
well-regulated
militia they also didn't put an age in
it and we have the right to bear arms
it's our right as Americans to to
possess these arms to carry these AR
these firearms and to use them to
protect ourselves how do how do people
treat you Carl when you when you walk
around
there well there there is some
harassment um I'm constantly having
photos taken of me I'm constantly
receiving death threats on social media
and it's just something that is part of
my life now having pictures taken of me
everywhere I go and the constant
constant harassment and death threats
obviously by doing a book and promoting
it in the way that you are on National
Television around the world you're going
to make yourself even more famous
Infamous whatever you want to call it um
is that is that something you're aware
of that you're deliberately consciously
doing
that I'm aware that it's going to bring
some more notoriety to my name and make
me more known but I think it's worth
that risk to share my story and share
what happened just in the hopes that
maybe somebody who else somebody else
who goes through a similar situation or
faces other trials in their life they
can read it and they can understand that
they're not alone and that this happens
to other people with the misjustice that
does happen in America okay KL
writtenhouse thank you for joining me I
appreciate
it uncensored next tonight as hungry
vegans vote to take meat off the menu at
War University depriving many students
of meat well debate it it's time to get
serious about fighting this Foody
[Music]
fascism we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know I love about
today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police appr Pro pal paltin
that is just not right you swear an off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan should have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
M in a box which he walked into a branch
of McDonald MC mous man mc mouseman mc
he should be easy enough to catch this
guy shouldn't he I mean he's got house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually share your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party I'm just kids think all they have
to do is take pictures of everything
just shut down Tik Tok problem solved
this is really unfair what what what's
unfair if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational can't can
you I've asked you two questions should
a mass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
joining me now is talk to contributor
Esther kru and associator to the of the
mirror Kevin mcgu just before we get to
vegans and vegan fascism uh I've named
the two Royals that were named in this
uh Dutch version of omen sc's book what
if you understand why journalists
weren't I'm glad you did name them I
think there are some concerns about
legal issues if it's denied by the two
people you you name but I just take the
view that if you can read it in Holland
why can't you read it in the United king
The View Esther that I don't believe
there ever was any racial undertone to
anything that was said of course
particularly when you see the two names
that have been put in this Dutch version
it's because the thing is what people
are forgetting was Megan wasn't there
for the conversation the Apparently
racist conversation she's just getting
she built her opinion based of what
Harry told her and she said apparently
the person said they were concerns about
how dark the child would they couldn't
even decide what year it was say exactly
and I'm like why would there be concerns
about the darkness of the child you look
Puerto Rican anyway I don't but if the
AL if the allegation the accusation the
charge is made against the people of the
stature seniority of the royal family as
you make it's an issue that has to be
debated you have to get to the of it I
think the moment a book is published in
another country and people in that
country were able to go to a bookstore
and buy it with these names in it it's
time that this faral anonymity that's
dominated this debate now for two and a
half years is just over let's just have
the debate what was actually said when
was it said who exactly said it to whom
what was the context and let the people
who've been accused of this actually say
what they would like to say but that
would require the palace booking and
Palace
to and they won't there's never going to
be a right of apply but I do think that
if har and Megan do say something about
omed sco's book it would be really
really disappointing well they've got to
they've got to denounce it and say they
had nothing to do with it the trouble is
Megan Markle denied last time being
involved in his book and then under oath
in a court case many months after it was
published was forced to admit actually I
did I emailed my AIDS telling them to
tell omed scobby she was a primary
source right as were a lot of her
friends and they all just disappeared
because someone told him about this
meeting about these letters I mean
between Charles and Megan marles and it
wasn't Charles um let's turn to vegan
fascist one of my favorite subjects so
thousands of students at War University
will be forced to go vegan after a
handful of activists voted for a meet
and dairy ban in institutions
cens um three establishments why do they
allow a vote in the first place why is
any exactly this is the thing why is it
anyone's business what choose to eat
Student Union you have votes you have
decisions no no not based on what people
are going to eat this isn't a farm
nobody's going to be forced to be a
vegan I think the F you can't eat
anything else there's nothing else on
the menu you you can go elsewhere you
can just go elsewhere 1400 st400
students will be offered plantbased crap
in my right which by the way there is no
scientific evidence to suggest is even
good for you in fact in fact the S of
evidence is the opposite that actually a
strict vegan diet is bad for you and
it's also you know my evidence who just
bailed out of the imity Jungle looking
terrible Grace Dent Grace Dent apart
from being a guardian columnist which
painful enough is a vegan there's my
proof I think that's a big jump right
look she couldn't even last a week in
there despite the fact she surrounded by
plants and bugs some vegan food is good
like like I think the Greg's vegan
sausage
Ro
in there a there's a serious Point here
why should we allow a small group of
people at a university to dictate how
thousands of students eat look if the
other students don't want it they can
overturn the vote and they can say bring
back beef bacon whatever you want that's
what that's what why was the vote held
in the first place I mean do they have
nothing better to do why don't they vote
on world peace you can literally vote on
anything else I think they probably do
that every other week actually yeah with
great vegan sausage RS I mean I've tried
the trou is you go everywhere now
everyone's got their little vegan vegan
ice cream vegan sh have you no have you
noticed vegan food is very heavily
processed I've never unless I'm seeing
them eat salad it's always like you know
what they do in France in France they
ban the use of meat language to sell
vegan products you're not allowed to say
Vegan sausage roll vegan steak right and
that's what we should do that here make
it illegal use your own language call it
GRL here's your GRL right it's T isn't
horrible but if you want it it's in the
GRL section leave the meat language to
me look look I've got to leave it there
that's it I've had my red meat for the
night thank you both very much indeed
great to see you all that's it from me
whatever you're up to keep it unsensed
and that means telling you what the
Dutch know good
[Music]
nights
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online R
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella scon
I rather like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sinak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police appr Pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking Li if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film